if you want to hear about how an old
McDonald's commercial inspired one of
the scenes of Pennywise in it then stick
around to the end of this video the 1990
adaptation of Stephen King's it directed
by Tommy Lee Wallace was originally
supposed to be an epic season length
affair covering much of the content from
the book but was cut down to a
two-parter for budgetary reasons some of
the remnants of that original story are
still left behind in the opening credits
we go through what is presumably Mike
Hamlin's photo album which includes the
group photo of the likely seven taken at
the junkyard and the haunted house that
stan visits which I'd interpret to be
the miniseries version of 29 he bolts
trades the place that the losers Club
first battles it as a group in the book
and a photo of this scene that Mike
couldn't have possibly been there for
where everybody who starts with being
Bill Beverly and Ben walk home together
the book contains more images of things
that Mikey couldn't have been there for
and couldn't have really ever even been
photographed at all and a photo of some
houses along the river which I'd
interpret to be West Broadway a
neighborhood filled with the rich
descendants of Barry's early Lumberjacks
settlers the opening scene shows the
final moments of a girl named loriann
when we meet at her she's singing the
itsy bitsy spider
[Music]
this is the first of many clues
foreshadowing the loser's club's final
battle with its word it takes the form
of a giant spider the up the waterspout
line refers to the fact that it's lives
in and travels using the sewer pipes
the first victim Laurieann is a
combination of two characters from the
book Lori Ann winter Barger a girl who
went missing in February 1985 while
going sledding and Matthew Clemens a boy
who was abducted from his tricycle also
if you look closely the girl on
rollerblades that goes past loriann on
the sidewalk is trying to land ski
behind a bike pretty hardcore Lord Ann's
mother tells her to come inside because
it's about to storm in the book Derry
has an unfortunate history of storms and
flooding during the reign of it and this
is probably a slight nod towards that
after the young girl's body is found the
police chief argues with Mike about
whether or not there's a killer in Derry
one of the Chiefs arguments is that one
of the missing boys was actually taken
by his father the boy's father to me
which is a reference to Laurie Ann
winter Barger from the book who police
concluded was most likely picked up by
the divorced father Mike finding the
picture of Georgie is a condensed
version of the events for the book where
police find the photo alongside the body
of Denis Torrio in the Barrens and Mike
later gets his hands on it after this
introduction scene Mike calls up each of
his old friends the first of which is
Bill den bro who apparently has acquired
the ability to type at the speed of
thoughts Tigard steps onto the moors as
the fog curls around his ankles he
shivers buttons his coat and walks on
disappearing into the mist a shadowy
figure lurches into frame dripping with
foul water and dark losing blood his
script mentioned someone disappearing
into the mist
maybe a reference to the missed another
Stephen King novel bill like many of
Kings characters serves as kind of an
extension of the author himself
for example bill tells his wife they're
gonna hire somebody to mangle one of my
books might as well be me Stephen King
would later try to readapt his novel The
Shining after being somehow unhappy with
how the director Stanley Kubrick
portrayed it in his legendary 1980 film
bill finds out about it returning and
flashes back to his childhood in young
Bill's room there are a lot of Easter
eggs and clues bill has a typewriter on
his desk a foreshadowing of his future
as a successful author the photo of The
Lone Ranger
on his wall references the book where
Bill is a big Lone Ranger fan and named
his bike silver after the lone Ranger's
horse there are a series of board games
on the Shelf one is called
circle cuts a reference to the promise
that he and his trans would make where
they stand in a circle and cut their
palms as a blood oath that if Pennywise
would ever return they would come back
to try to defeat it he's also got me not
the game that bill and his friends
played to try to make it look like they
weren't trying to make silver bullets in
the garage and Parcheesi a game that
they would all play at their Clubhouse
in Barents I also spotted a comic called
comets a clue about how it actually
arrived in Derry as a crashing comets
millions of years ago and a wolf photo
possibly connected to one of the most
often used forms of it's the werewolf
form bill makes his brother George II
the paper boat which eventually falls
into the hands of Pennywise the
Pennywise storm drain scene is the same
as it is in the book which is a
reference to this old McDonald's
commercial from the 1960s McDonald's
hamburger delicious mom told me never to
talk to strangers
[Music]
well your mother's right as always but
I'm Ronald McDonald give me a man
that'll take very wise of you dad
Georgie very wise indeed I Georgie and
Pennywise the dancing cloud
Oh Jorgie so now we know each other by
now we all know what happens to Georgie
and the memory comes back to Bill in a
rush yes George
he didn't just die next losers Club
member that Mike calls is Ben Hanscom
who reminisces to his date about how he
used to be fast
[Music]
bet your fern I was we should say that
his kids be vet your friend not sure why
they change this but in the book the
phrase that they used to say is you bet
your fern not fern also does anyone know
the reason that he has to set his phone
up like this this is seriously always
bothered me I mean the guy is supposedly
a master architect and yet he can't
figure out how to set up his telephone
on the desk next to his booze come on
Ben Ben flashes back to his arrival in
Derry
introducing himself to his new class
there's a picture of US President
Richard Nixon who took office in 1969
which suggests that this movie takes
place in a different time period than
the novel where the past events took
place in 1958 that or this teacher was
just somehow a big fan of Nixon before
he got into office there's also a
geometry problem on the board asking for
the circumference and radius of a circle
when Ben gets the call from Mike in the
present there's also some artwork on
Ben's wall featuring the symbol for pi
pi is the ratio of a circles
circumference to its diameter and the
losers Club is often described as a
wheel or circle when all seven of them
are together the circle feels complete
so they fear that they won't be as
strong after the death of Stan but pi is
a ratio that always comes out the same
no matter the size of the circle so in a
way it suggests that even without Stan
the group will still be powerful we see
this bond start to form as the group
starts small with bill Eddie and Ben and
it's in this scene in the Barrens that
Ben references one obscure detail from
the book
after school gets out Ben eventually
finds himself with a bill and Eddie in
the Barrens
and Eddie is having an asthma attack
when bill gets back with the medication
Ben expresses his concern up into a
comer like I'm dr. Kildare this line is
a little reference to Bill's worries in
the novel where he also mistakenly
refers to a coma as a coma the scene
where Ben sees Pennywise appear in the
water is a reference to the part in the
book where he sees it as a mummy on the
frozen canal in the winter of 50 AAS the
hand of the monster that reaches out of
the water for him is later used in Pet
Sematary - but you already know that if
you saw my things you missed episode the
next character Mike calls is Beverley
who's in Chicago why is it that all
receptionists are always named Pam I
mean is it something that's decided at
Birth oh look at this baby it looks like
she wants to be a receptionist we must
continue the tradition I shall call you
Pat but anyways Beverley flees from her
abusive husband Tom Rogan and the way
she throws the bottles as she's making
her escape is very similar to how she
throws rocks at the Bowers gang during
the apocalyptic rock fights she ends up
getting in a cab which she hails in
front of the sign for Ditka's Northwest
who of course is duh coach of the Super
Bowl champion 85 Bears the novel takes
place in 1985 and there is a small
reference to de bears when they're all
at the Chinese restaurants and after a
scare from hits they try to act as if
nothing has happened when the waitress
comes by and mike tells bill he likes
the Bears chances this year in Beverly
splash back when she's meeting all the
boys in the Barrens Eddy gets upset at
Richie for calling him Eddie spaghetti
don't call me Eddie spaghetti you love
it Eddie it's what makes you so chuckle
issues chuckle Isha's I love that word I
need to start using that on a regular
basis Bev returns home to find her dad
watching an episode of 77 Sunset Strip
something that Richie thinks about after
his
counter with it in the book that's one
Bev hears the voices calling out to her
in the drain in the book we recognize
them as the missing kids of Derry but in
this version they have different names
who are you Victoria burrows is one of
the casting directors for the series and
Matthew O'Connor was the name of a
producer Bev's dad is unable to see the
blood so she makes up a lie that turns
out to be not a lie when they fight the
spider under the drains of Derry thirty
years later crawled out of the drain and
it used to crawl back down kick the next
one we meet is the Chuckle ishes Eddie
Casper in this version he lives with his
mother who somehow hasn't aged really
it's not too far of a cry from the novel
where he has a wife that strongly
resembles his mother to the point that
even Eddie is aware of it the wife and
mother characters are largely the same
no pun intended one of the things that
the wife wants in the book is for Eddie
to stay in New York so he can get her Al
Pacino's autograph miniseries Eddie gets
one of his limo drivers to take him to
the train station and makes a comment
about wanting him to be the one to do
the Pacino job all right I want you to
do the Pacino job yourself
Eddie's flashback involves a scene that
he wasn't there for in the book the day
out at the horror movie matinee and what
a horrible audience I mean is this
really what movies were like back then
the werewolf film that they see is
important because that's what gives
Richie his fear something that it takes
the form of later in the episode the
group ribs Richie for pissing off the
bullies at the movie theatre and he
plays it off as just a practical joke
see die of boredom
I mean are we men or are we mice this
phrase originates from a 1700s poem but
in this case it's a small nod to another
phrase that the kids use in the novel
which is associated with building up the
courage to fight it and before we move
on and Ben and Eddie are transfixed on
this creepy structure in the Barrens
this is something I've genuinely always
found super creepy and still do and they
almost Castle like appearance of it
makes me think of how the losers see the
inner layer of it and think of how it
almost looks like a Cathedral meanwhile
immediately trips and then the police
go away No now that's what I call
chuckle Isha's all right let's get back
on topic here Mike makes his next call
to Ritchie and we can see that he's
still a horror movie buff based on this
monster picture on the wall and his
cemetery gate themed dress shirt Ritchie
tells his manager he's gotta leave town
and someone will have to cover for him
on the show funny enough in real life
Jay Leno would take over just two years
after it's came out on The Tonight Show
the show that Ritchie show is basically
emulating Ritchie flashes back to his
time as a young boy in the Barrens and
Bill is telling the group a story they
had learned to be strong again they'd
beaten the dragon with their magic
stones nothing would ever be the same
again this could be either a reference
to the rock fights which would make
Henry and his goons the Dragons of this
story or it may refer to shooting the
silver slugs at Pennywise which bill
refers to at one point as stones they go
around saying what they all want to be
when they grow up
Eddie states he wants to be a train
conductor a reference to the book where
Eddie likes playing around the train
yard and one day a conductor throws him
a box and instructs him to bring it home
to his mother Stan says he wants to be
an ornithologist he's big into
bird-watching in a novel but his hobby
is barely acknowledged in the series
they find out that there's been yet
another murder and everyone is really
down in the dumps the next day at school
I mean look at this kid
[Music]
honestly it's a little bit chuckle ishes
bowers confronts richie about the
incident at the movie theater
- which richie asks an implication that
henry and his gang are the Three Stooges
Larry Moe and Curly bowers interrogate
some asking which one of them threw the
soda I mean does he seriously not know
play back the club yeah you know I'm not
quite sure who did it but anyway
Richie's flashback ends with the entire
lunchroom laughing at him when he brings
up his werewolf encounter one detail I
noticed was that Richie's lamp is
modeled as an Indian chief and in the
book Richie is one of the two members to
make it through the Indian smoke hole
ceremony and have a vision that teaches
them more about anyone the next
character to have a flashback is Mike
himself but first we see the dari
manuscript he's working out on the desk
there's something about him being a good
student and something about it only
waking up every thirty years as opposed
to 27 from the novel and the ice nine
kills song the manuscript is essentially
the framing device for Tina's entire
novel and there are introduced chapters
scattered throughout where we actually
get to read from it directly we can see
that Mike is researching about Jerry in
the newspapers from the 1930s his desk
is also stacked with phone books for
each of the cities that the losers now
live in such as the Atlanta phonebook
for Stan URIs Mike is chased by the
bullies in his flashback and as he runs
there's a poster advertising a circus
which may or may not be a part of its
influence on Darrin the losers Club
protects Mike from Henry by throwing
rocks at him and his goons what isn't a
surprise if you tell him about it now is
it him after this fight Mike joins up
with the losers and together they flip
through the photo album of dairy's
history if you pause during the page
flipping shot one of the pictures is a
grave marker could be a foreshadowing of
a graveyard scene that would come in
part two or just a connection to the
impending death of Stan on a personal
note this was one of the scariest scenes
ever I watched this movie as a kid and
probably sixth grade and instantly loved
it but it definitely puts spooky
thoughts in my head whenever
was around a drain by myself but this
scene was the scariest whenever I saw
this still image around the internet I
just start to think like maybe it could
start moving and reach them
the unexpected sound that Pennywise
makes their reactions and just the fact
that Tim Curry is looking right into the
camera I love it it gives me chills but
enough of my personal experiences
because we've still got one more
character to cover and that is Stan the
man URIs it's pretty funny that if you
take a closer look at the stuff in
Stan's house he and his wife had this
lamp of a boy playing the flutes because
27 years after this miniseries came out
the movie version of Stan is afraid of
this woman in the painting who plays the
flute when the phone rings you can spot
Stan's birds can item given to him by
his father in the book which he uses to
ward off it by demonstrating that he
believes in all these rare species of
birds that he's never seen before but he
does not believe in it you can also find
his binoculars used for bird-watching
and these bird statues by the stairs the
time comes for the losers to confront
it's down in the sewers but first and
ran belch get a hold of Stan but before
they can do anything they're attacked by
it's in the form of these bright lights
that have ducked belch and make Henry go
crazy this is a representation of the
dead lights the true form of its that
Bill battles in the macro verse in the
novel the kids aren't able to interpret
the actual shape of the dead lights in
the book so in this adaptation they're
literal bright lights the sound of the
dead lights is the same sound that can
be heard when the werewolf in the school
basement turns into Pennywise so it may
be associated with its changing forms
when Stan joins back up with his friends
the light comes after them and knocks
them all over and you can briefly see a
strange shape floating over them which
we later find out is the underbelly of
the spider in part two I always thought
the line that Stan chants with his eyes
closed was kind of odd but I looked it
up and it's actually the Boy Scout Oath
which makes sense because that's kind of
his thing in this series he's always got
the Boy Scout uniform on but we don't
really get to know him as well as we do
in the 2017 adaptation or in the book
through the lucky sevens combined
efforts they're able to defeat it and
send Pennywise retreating deeper into
the sewers bill urges them not to let it
get away and they grab hold of the white
clown love but it's insectile claws poke
through and they all see the appendage
of the spider momentarily before it
retract down into the drain one last
clue about what they would be up against
in the second part and there are more
things you missed in that sex
so make sure you're subscribed to see
these worlds from new horrors every week
bring the death penalty for
notifications and I'll see you next week
when we cover part 2 assuming we both
survive
[Music]